the story with you in the world of
lobbyists okay and that's the business
you've been in since 1980
you know when you got into the business
you know when they talk about you going
to jail what did you really go get
sentenced 47 months for some are saying
russia some are saying the 10 million
dollar loan from the oligarch some are
saying the 60 million dollars from
ukraine what was the real reason at the
end that you got 47 months there was no
10 million dollar loan from the
oligarchs there was no launch of
oligarchs there was a bank law that they
accused me of uh u.s bank um
what i was
villainized for was being pro putin you
know uh traitor to my country
uh
um
you know what i was convicted of were
legal issues which i talked about in the
book uh that uh that i'd already been
cleared up on
or have been cleared up on in in the
fair issues on the tax issues on the the
f bar which is the offshore accounts
issues
and i'm not going to get into them today
but uh but in the book i get into them
in detail
um and you need to understand the
context and that was exactly what
weissman's strategy was was to confuse
the context to make me a villain in the
in the uh in the media and then get me
convicted on just over charging and just
dropping hundreds of thousands of
documents millions of pages and putting
me in solitary putting me in solitary so
i couldn't really prepare myself weisman
being the right hand guy for mueller
right
weissman ran at least my case he ran
they ran it but i think he ran the whole
special
what role did leticia leticia jackson
play the teaser james i'm sorry natasha
james play no she's not she's the
attorney general in new york but she was
trying to go after trump you know
god knows how many different things that
we're trying to find they couldn't find
anything except for you know the ceo you
know who
apparently trump gave him
ferrari or something like that they
couldn't find anything else so i guess
the question for you would be to follow
from 1980
till you go on
uh uh again the 47 months
how often ford reagan all these guys you
work with how often were you a target
the way you were at target the moment
you started helping out trump
never
no so you've never been a target like
the i don't know so why why this level
of hatred towards
targeting trump versus every everybody
else you supported was also republican
what's different between trump and
everyone else
the world has changed i mean number one
social media
uh uh number two i mean social media was
trump's uh
helped trump
facilitate trump's election
and it dominated social trump's
presidency um you know we used to have
in the going back to four days there was
one new cycle and you got you used
between eight in the morning until about
three in the afternoon to get on the
three network news programs that night
uh and that that was the way you built
your your strategy for the day by the
time you know the second reagan second
term and jim baker mastered this we had
two cycles we had the morning cycle in
the afternoon cycle so that we dominated
was in the news in the evening and what
you saw in the papers in the morning um
today you have 24 hour cycle and
uh
you've also had journalism
mainstream journalism
change
uh it used to be that you know the fact
checkers were the most important part of
any write any any articles you read in
the non-editorial pages
fact checkers don't exist anymore
it's first to file not first to get the
facts
and and that's driven by the social
media to some respect and it's the
social media has you know the is
dominated the the mainstream medias
because the mainstream media how do
these new reporters
grow grown into national celebrities
the articles they get they get they get
they get to be writing and also the the
coverage they get on the tv talk shows
and the clicks
how many clicks so that if their
articles get clicks they the more clicks
they get uh the more attention that
brings to it to them the more attention
it brings to them it's helped their
economics uh and
what gets clicks
news or or or i wonder
i wanna i wanna say okay it's social
media but
nixon got targeted hardcore you know
when they were after him you know a lot
you know
we can give names of people of course
post media coming out first debate being
john f kennedy and nixon on tv where it
was no longer radio on radio nixon's
winning on tv he's not but
the targeting has happened for a while
maybe not at the levels that we have
today right intensity intensity so but
why do that's what i want to know forget
the social media side why why
specifically towards trump
well
again well i think the main reason for
trump and i get into this in the book
is because
he threatened the system
not democrats the system
he was going to drain the swamp the
swamp wasn't the democrats the swamp was
washington the swamp was new york the
swamp was the elites versus the people
the to quote hillary clinton the basket
of deplorables that's they were they
were coming coming not since andrew
jackson
were where the people
coming to the streets of washington the
way they were under trump
really i mean you look at
all of the
the
changes the fdr uh
even abraham lincoln
you
you didn't have
an attack on the system the way you did
when trump or andrew jackson depending
on how you want to do it became
president and
so and and they weren't ready for it in
trump's case
nobody was ready for trump to be
president except trump's supporters and
they were the quiet still to quote nixon
silent majority i mean they were hoping
uh i felt trump was going to win the
whole time
in 2016. i wrote a memo which they tried
and weissman tried to make into a
something it wasn't in on thursday
before the election in 2016 that i sent
to
the president to jared and to write
reince priebus who was running the rc at
the time
where i said
that trump is going to win on 2 on
tuesday
and i wrote the memo on thursday
specifically because i felt that there
was still time on the week before
for clinton to change if clinton has run
a smart last 10 days of the campaign she
could have won i'm not saying she would
have but she could have by thursday
it was too late she couldn't do in my
mind what had to be done in the states
where i thought nick or trump would win
so i wrote a memo that said
that it's really important this weekend
that we get out there and make people
understand we're going to win i said the
media's not going to believe it
in the memo
but we have to put the marker down
because when we do hit on this on
tuesday i said
they're going to no one's going to
understand how this happened and they're
going to try and say we stole the
election
uh and we didn't
um
some of them some of what i asked for
they suggested it happened happened but
i'm not saying it was because of my memo
um
but my point was
that the system wasn't expecting rig uh
trump to win and so the combination of
he's going to drain the swamp nobody
expected him to be standing on wednesday
after the election
the people crying like schools teachers
unions closing schools because
yeah i mean
when did we ever have that happen when
did we ever have that happen
but that became the defining
atmosphere for trump's presidency so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]